. This is very, very fun to watch.
Over the last few weeks, former Democratic
presidential candidate Pete Budig Edge has
been appearing on Fox News pretty often, and
he's been laying out some smack downs that
are truly a delight to watch.
It's just a pleasure to watch.
It's a clinic on how to deal with Fox News.
So Mayor Pete has been doing appearances as
a surrogate of an adviser to Joe Biden and
Mayor Pete.
Has this.
It's almost like a natural ability to casually
deliver hilarious and brutal attack lines
that you just have to see.
This first one might be my favorite mayor.
Pete is interviewed by Fox News anchors Martha
MacCallum and Bret Baer.
This was on the eve of the vice presidential
debate.
The question was, Kamala Harris and Joe Biden
have, or at least during the campaign, had
different views on health care.
And they wanted to put Mayor Pete in a position
to have to explain or defend.
Kamala has this view.
Joe Biden has this view.
How do you square it?
What's the right view?
And Mayor Pete brilliantly points out that
if you look at Trump and Pence.
There is also a contrast from the primary
from, you know, between their views, which
is that Pence is an evangelical Christian.
And Trump is a president caught with a porn
star.
And the looks on the faces of the Fox News
anchors are just priceless.
Back to my original question about the things
that, you know, when you run for president,
you have a record on all of these issues.
And then we've seen that record and her stance
on them changing over time.
So there's no doubt she's going to be asked
about that tonight.
Can you give us some insight into what she
might say to justify why she was for Medicare
for all then and is not for it now, for example?
Well, there's a classic parlor game of trying
to find a little bit of daylight between running
mates.
And if people want to play that game, we could
look into why an evangelical Christian like
Mike Pence wants to be on a ticket with the
president caught with a porn star or how he
feels about the immigration policy that he
called unconstitutional before he decided
to team up with Donald Trump.
Folks want to play that game.
We could do it all night.
But I think what most Americans want to hear
about is, are our families going to be better
protected than they have been by this president
who's failed to secure America in the face
of one of the most dangerous things ever to
happen to our country.
You actually get the feeling that this is
fun for Pete Boutet, Judge, it's a game which
I have to tell you I love.
I've been on Fox News a couple of times, and
I also see it as a joke in a game for myself.
I don't see it as serious journalism.
I see it more as what can I do to make this
interesting?
Pete Boota judge much better than me at making
it really interesting.
And there's more of these.
Here's one where Chris Wallace tried to get
Pete booted.
Judge again on this primary stuff, saying,
do you stand by your criticisms of Joe Biden
when you were running against him?
And Mayor Pete just handles it perfectly.
Well, what I know is we definitely need to
turn the page even more now than when I was
running for president a year ago.
And what we need to turn the page from is
a president who is incapable of hand handling
a public health crisis that has now cost almost
a quarter of a million American lives, thrown
our economy into total wreckage and has clearly
no plan to do anything about it.
So, yeah, let's turn the page.
And we have a very clear choice between two
very different futures for this country and
any differences that we have.
Remember when everybody was was hand-wringing,
saying, how can the Democrats possibly unify?
Look how unified we are now.
You've got Democrats from across the spectrum,
from the left to the center, joining with
independents and Republicans, because we can
all see what's at stake here.
I mean, I can't think of an election in modern
history where the choice has been this stark.
And I know what side I'm on.
What's brilliant about this and perfectly
done is that Mayor Pete goes directly at the
top issues for voters economy and covered
and turns the question completely around and
wraps it up with a bow.
And especially if the audience was a Fox News,
you know, typical Fox News audience.
And they were hoping to see Pete, you know,
up against the ropes for Pete to know that
Trump is failing in approval on economy and
corona virus and to turn it around and to
go right at those topics is absolutely perfect.
Here is Mayor Pete calling Trump out for not
respecting his own followers by stuffing them
into rooms during a pandemic.
Look, we've seen the vice president, Vice
President Biden, campaigning across the country.
There's one key difference, which is he's
never going to stuff his supporters into a
room without masks in an indoor space over
the objections of local public health officials.
When you do that, you show a level of fundamental
disrespect for your own supporters.
So Martha MacCallum started to push back and
Mayor Pete didn't back down.
Let's take a look.
The point is that there's respect for the
health and safety of the people attending
the event.
You set a certain tone when you lead people
to a certain place.
And if you lead people to danger, you bear
some responsibility for that.
In Tulsa and more recently, Nevada, he led
people into danger.
And you know how he can tell that?
You can tell what a dim view he has of the
intelligence of his own supporters was.
Something they were made to do was sign a
waiver saying they wouldn't sue him if they
got sick and died.
Think about what that sense for truth, for
the respect that he has very, very well done.
And then lastly, here is Mayor Pete.
This is now the day after the V.P. debate.
He was interviewed by Fox and Friends, specifically
Steve Doocy.
And he is going right at Donald Trump's comments
about troops being suckers.
And remember, Mayor Pete is a veteran and
Steve Doocy tries to interrupt twice.
Mayor Pete just doesn't allow it.
I also appreciated that she stood up for American
troops.
You know, the president, United States calling
those who served suckers and losers, saying
they didn't understand what's in it for them
while he was standing on the the hallowed
ground of sexual sin.
But, Mayor, you know, the president who wants
to serve knows what Section 60 means and indeed,
in the way he talked about the, you know,
folks like John McCain.
I hate to interrupt you, but, you know, the
president has denied that particular story.
Right.
But we know he's lying because, you know,
even in the middle of his term, you know,
he's Lundestad said, I never called.
Well, because part of his denial was he said,
I never called John McCain a loser.
And anybody with Twitter can go and see where
he did so to believe that he was lying and
that part of his sentence, but not another
part.
Remember, this is the guy who back when he
was a wealthy young man in New York, born
to privilege, thought to himself.
I'm going to let some soccer go to Vietnam
and my place and pretended to be disabled.
I mean, if you really believe the president
now on this kind of stuff, I've got a bridge
to sell you.
All right.
Really, really good stuff.
I mean, really just a clinic on how to deal
with Fox News.
And in each of those clips, you see something
different.
But what's common to all of them is you see
the anchors faces, Steve Doocy, Martha, Martha
MacCallum.
They don't know how to handle this because
Mayor Pete is brutally handling them and doing
it so quickly.
Just really, really well done.
I hope we see much, much more of this, particularly
in the lead up to and even after this Thursday
night's presidential debate for.
Which I hope you will join me.
I will be live starting half an hour before
the debate, maybe even 45 minutes on YouTube,
Twitch and Facebook.
Don't miss it.
Also, don't miss today's bonus show.
We will talk about the Jeffrey Toobin fiasco.
We will talk about Slovakia testing the entire
country for Corona virus.
And we will also talk about the New Zealand
election results.
A very interesting election results out of
New Zealand, a country that has handled the
virus very, very well.
So get instant access to the bonus show one
of two ways.
Become a member at join Pacman dot com or
become a patron at Patrie on dot com slash
David Pakman show.